the fact that
he proposed and you never told us
yeah
Tristan proposed to you yeah
yeah you heard that right Tristan
proposed you yeah
Khloe Kardashian reveals Tristan
Thompson popped the question isn't that
crazy okay just a little refresher
during the season 2 premiere of who loss
the Kardashians fans got an up close and
personal look at the August birth of
Coco and Tristan's baby boy Tristan and
I are I don't even know if I want to say
Tristan and I I am having another baby
and the good American founder explained
why she did not discuss her son in the
episodes leading up to the birth of
their child
I want to keep this private for like my
loved ones as long as possible and not
have this Beast some media frenzy that
people get to just play with and run
with rewind to six to six months earlier
and that's where episode 2 picked
taking us right to the aftermath of
Chloe's split from the NBA star amid his
paternity Scandal without any mention
that they're having a baby together we
were in the best place we were
so when we're in the peak of our
relationship you go ahead and cheat on
me God like I don't even want to know
what you do in the worst of our
relationship
I'm just like shame on me almost I know
better and I didn't do better because I
had so much hope and like faith and
during that chat with her sister Kim
reveals that Tristan actually proposed
to Chloe in December 2020 but no one in
her famous fam even knew about it until
February 2021 when Kim followed up with
Tristan he was going to propose to her
on Valentine's Day which was like a year
since they had drama so this is like
last Valentine's Day and then I called
him like the day after and I was like
hey I never heard anything from Chloe oh
my god did you propose
and he was like oh yeah I did in
December
oh my God she didn't tell us so I know
what you're thinking did she say yes and
what I said I said I I need to make sure
this is a totally different relationship
because I want to be proud to say I'm
engaged to anyone and that's why I said
you know I'm not comfortable accepting
this right now because I'm not excited
to tell my family yeah no
she said no and as hurtful as that
probably was for him to hear it was the
truth I'm not ever gonna
accept something and give someone false
hope and I said that to him Bravo Chloe
Bravo I don't know if someone asked me I
would just have to say yes and I feel so
bad and while Coco does not confirm if
the giant diamond ring she was sporting
in early 2021 was the ring Tristan
proposed with we gotta hand it to her
pun intended she's really bearing it all
on the new reality series tune in
because you never know what's gonna
happen and when ET chatted with the
Kardashian Jenner crew back in April
Chloe explained why she's being so
transparent
I think for every sister we have
different boundary levels and we all try
to respect that and like your boundaries
are allowed to change and mine will
probably change later but what is in the
media is sort of things that we feel we
need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives especially the
older ones we've been doing this for so
long now Chloe says that healing isn't
an overnight process but she's working
on it going through what I went through
with Tristan was incredibly hard the
hardest part about it all is training
yourself to unlove someone of course
Chloe and Tristan also share a
four-year-old daughter true everyone has
to handle their co-parenting situation
in their own style it's hard work for
all parties it's a beautiful thing to
get along with each other and for your
kids to see that and a source recently
told E.T Chloe is doing well and trying
to gauge the dynamic of her relationship
with Tristan but that will come in time
right now her focus is her baby
foreign
[Music]